how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things super
all things marvel and of course
everything relating to the mcu
and over the weekend not only marvel and
mcu fans were going crazy but
harry styles fans as well we're going
crazy as there's been a report that
harry styles is going to be
in a marvel mcu film and to top it all
off the report says that he's already
filmed it that means it's going to be a
project coming up
very soon it's a marvel phase 4 project
and there's only really a few options
that it could be for him to be making an
mcu debut in a marvel movie and we're
going to break down which one that we
think it is in this video but first
big congratulations to youtube user
userilla43 for being the winner of this
week's funko pop giveaway
gladiator hulk send me an email in the
email in my description and i'll get
your funko pop and for this week we're
giving away a
thanos from avengers in game with his
sword funko pop all you have to do to
enter subscribe like the video and leave
a comment down below so the news about
harry styles coming to the mcu comes
from
chris tapley from netflix justin kroll
tweeted exclusive in his first
acting gig since dunkirk harry styles is
set to join the ensemble of
olivia wilde next directing job don't
worry
darling but then chris tapley from
netflix tweeted out saying
second if we're counting the marvel
movie no one knows he's in
so here are the main points that are
really important that you need to know
first off when chris tapley says second
if we're counting the marvel movie no
one knows he's in he's referring to
it's going to be his second acting gig
since dunkirk because the marvel film
would be his
first acting gig since dunkirk and that
means he's already finished
filming now right away that only really
leaves a few projects because only a few
are done filming
and really only two are completely done
with their films and that is the black
widow
film and the eternals and it's most
likely going to be the eternals and the
reason that it's most likely going to be
the eternals is because
last september richard madden who was
going to be playing icarus in the
eternals film
he said that there were other
unannounced castings for the eternals
so castings that nobody knows about
people are going to be in the film that
we don't know about yet and that falls
in line with the tweet from chris tapley
when he says if we're counting the
marvel movie no one knows
he's in so here's the big question if
he's in the eternals who exactly is he
going to be playing
well right now it seems like the best
guess that we have is that he's going to
be playing the character
star fox the brother of thanos now
remember
thanos was actually born of two eternal
parents
alars otherwise known as mentor and
suicide but thanos happened to inherit
the deviant gene which is why he came
out purple and a little bit scarred
however thanos's brother eros otherwise
known as starfox did not come out with a
deviant gene he is a pure
eternal born to the same parents that
thanos was born to
and unlike thanos star fox is actually
good star fox is an eternal that means
his job is to protect earth he served as
a member of the avengers and
even the dark guardians and he's opposed
his brother thanos many many times
or we could say that thanos opposed him
now star fox is a pretty interesting
character and quite honestly harry
styles
would probably make a pretty good star
fox he's a loving
carefree person very much the opposite
of thanos who has the ability to
psychically control people's emotions
however he is kind of a bit of a
womanizer which i'm sure marvel will
tone down
or take out altogether in the film but
he's a very charming person which would
mean harry styles would make for a
pretty good fit
so based off of everything that we know
it seems like this is the character that
harry styles is most likely to play
in the mcu in the eternals film and it
is very interesting that marvel did such
a good job at keeping this
under wraps harry styles a huge
celebrity
filmed a marvel film without anybody
knowing but let me know what you think
about this news do you think it could be
another character in another movie or do
you think he's probably playing the
brother of thanos
star fox let me know down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you stay up to date on all the latest
mcu news for live updates and more
giveaways you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof